[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAMIEN JOHNSON:
--enterprise applications
with SAP and Google.
I am Damien Johnson,
I've been an architect
with what we call the Google
Business Unit within SAP
since last September.
So we've established a good
working partnership along
with a good market partnership.
And today's goal is hopefully
to cover everything that's
top of mind with everyone
from our customers
as well as our
partner community.
And before I start
anything, I have
to give my safe
harbor statement,
because I do have some future,
forward-facing documentation
in there and such.
But beyond that, let's
see-- this is what we're
going to endeavor to cover.
We have a lot to cover
in the 50 minutes or so,
and I'm going to try to see
if I can leave time for Q&A.
And we'll go through the current
enterprise drivers, i.e.,
what is the requirement out in
the business from our customers
that drives this
kind of innovation.
We're going to look at
the intelligent suite
or intelligent enterprise
architecture, how SAP brings
those components together.
And then the next
point being, how
we look at the technical
footprint on how
that intelligent enterprise
functions within the GCP
framework and make
use of GCP services.
And then lastly, we're going to
look at some example use cases.
Again, some of these
are product ties,
some are prototypes
that we've been
developing with our
customers along these lines.
So feel free to think
of some questions.
Like I said, I don't
think we've got time
to do interactive
sessions-- we're
going to have one afterwards.
So what do we already know?
I think from the point of view
of artificial intelligence,
machine learning,
IoT, instant insights,
they are all requirements
of the business world,
as well as the consumer
world nowadays.
The other aspect is that
it's taken for granted
or it's expected that
the embedded machine
learning and analytics
needs to provide
that built-in guidance, or even
automation at the enterprise
level.
And then the last one is the
conversational applications.
It's the new user experience.
So I always said, does
that mean that all the UX
designers are out of work now?
And I don't think so.
But generally, it's
the way to go forward,
and that's something we're
going to also discuss--
how SAP and Google
are working together
to provide that into
the enterprise world,
i.e., taking the Google Home
experience into the enterprise
itself.
So when I talk about the
intelligent enterprise
or the intelligent world, I like
to go back a couple of years
and talk about this.
I won't tell you where I started
on this little time line.
You can just guess, but
it is quite far back.
But it is on there though.
So that's also good.
We've gone through these many
iterations as you can see.
At the top, you see all the kind
of traditional architectural
frameworks that started off on
the mainframe client server,
go to cloud, and
mobile, et cetera.
And now, what we internally
call the intelligent technology
server area.
The ones below that is kind
interesting to note as well.
Forget the technology, look
at the enabling technologies
there that you can see.
Everybody is familiar
with those things.
And I remember the days of when
I started into this computer
industry, back in the 86's
and late into the '90s,
you went to work
and you actually
had the latest technology.
Because I had an IBM XT to
make use of in Lotus 1 2 3.
And all I had at home was
a Vic 20 Home Computer.
And then you come to the modern
day and it's kind of switched.
You're finding that the
consumer has the latest tech,
and the enterprise
is now the laggard.
So that's where we're
looking at in terms
of how we're trying to bring
the intelligent technologies,
to bring it all the way
down into the customer value
creation as you can see here.
We want to be about the
intelligent enterprise,
meaning that it's
beyond just automation,
it's beyond just that what we
call the digital transformation
and making everything
in real time.
So look at this, and could I
say, tell me something new.
One of the things I
always like to talk about
is the fact that the core
backend systems are now
engaging at the edge.
The gentleman asked me, am
I going to talk about CRM
and supply chain, and ERP?
Yes.
The big difference nowadays is
it's not in the back office,
it's the front office now.
Actually, it's beyond
the front office,
it's directly in the consumers'
hands most of the time.
The other aspects of
this I talk about,
is the rate at which
can redefine or refactor
the backend is inversely
proportional to the complexity.
And backend systems are complex.
So that's where the
conundrum really sits there.
And then lastly, expectations
and experience matter.
Going back to that
consumer expectations being
brought into the enterprise.
Obviously, actually,
it's nothing new.
But it's worth restating
that, because in terms
of what we're
trying to do here is
to make all of these things
which are impediments
and turn them into
opportunities of how we actually
now make use of
these technologies
to empower the business.
So with that, this slide
is a very short summary
of how SAP looks at
the intelligence suite
or intelligent enterprise.
You may be familiar with the
classic scenarios of bimodal IT
where you have the
back office functions,
and then you have the
accelerating innovation layer.
So what I like to refer
to this, is really
looking at you've got the
back office capabilities
and how to steer the company,
how to run your company.
And those are traditionally RP.
That's obviously the
heart and soul of
or the DNA from SAP from 40
years of developing hardcore,
backend course
enterprise applications.
The trick is now to pivot
from all that information
and make it
consumer-facing and going
more into the other right-hand
side of the equation, i.e.,
engaging at the edge
and making innovations
happen in a much faster cycle.
So how does SAP look
at doing these things?
So it's a bit of an eye chart.
It's just to show the breadth
and depth of the solutions
that SAP brings to the table.
So this is the traditional
capabilities all the way
from the customer experience
through manufacturing, people
engagement, and
spend management.
So I'm assuming a
fair number of you
are going to go back
to the hotel, or Friday
if you're a
procrastinator like me,
and do your expenses on Concur.
So we cover a full
spectrum of interactions
within the enterprise
application space.
And the big difference
from our point of view
is the fact that we've seen
the need for all of this
to work seamlessly together,
to create that end-to-end flow.
And as you can see, down
here we targeted or call
it the Intelligence suite.
But in order to have a fully
functioning Intelligence suite,
we have to provide
those integrations,
we have to provide the master
data, and the orchestration.
And the business
objects there is not
Business Objects the analytics,
it's business objects,
meaning the business objects.
I am a business partner,
you're an employee.
A sales order is
a business object,
because we're going
to talk about how
in the intelligent enterprise
you're going to actually invoke
and consume business services
derived from those business
objects,
If you look at this, to go on
about the intelligence suite,
what's the underlying
constituents that
make up the Intelligence suite?
So you can see
here the top layer,
which is all those business
solutions that I explained.
Some are traditional
on-prem scenarios--
what we call our digital
core that started life back
as an ERP system.
It's now transformed into the
main component called S/4HANA.
S/4HANA, obviously,
runs on-prem,
and we have a cloud
version as well.
And just like our
customers, they're
running that
version in the cloud
on IS providers such as Good
Cloud platform, which is now
fully certified for those
solutions, along with all
the other line of
business solutions
that traditionally have
been more SAS-M based.
How does this all
become cohesive
into the Intelligence suite?
As you can see here, there's
a lot of technologies
involved in the middle there.
The traditional stuff that
gentleman asked about--
is it all about
machine learning?
Yes, it's all about
machine learning.
Is it about conversational AI?
Yes.
Is it about real-time
analytics and data
driven decision making?
All of that, yes.
But that's a bucket
of technologies,
and a bucket of technologies
that is evolving and developing
very, very rapidly.
And as I mentioned
before, the problem
with enterprise applications,
generally speaking,
is the ability to
pivot very quickly.
It takes a lot of
time, because there's
an intrinsic built-in
interdependence
of business processes.
It's not easy to just
change it on-the-fly here,
because that change can have a
tremendous ripple effect down
there.
So the problem
is, how do you now
make use of the
innovative technologies
in the context of that
enterprise applications?
And that's where we're
really looking at leveraging
that digital platform.
So as I mentioned, that's
really the frontside
of the Intelligence suite.
Now, if we look at this in an
architectural component style,
the core of enabling that
from SAP's point of view
for our customers is this
thing SAP Cloud Platform.
So this is the core
engine that enables
the brokering of our
enterprise capabilities
into the world of
digital services,
be it from GCP services,
or anybody else's services
for that matter.
But based on the--
obviously, from
my point of view,
as you can see
from my t-shirt, I
have a slight bias in
the way I'm working.
Obviously, I'm working
with Google Cloud teams
in terms of integrating their
technology into the business
functions within the SAP
business applications.
The four areas that
you can see here--
the connected
enterprise scenario,
that's the traditional
business suite components
I just talked about.
Insight driven activities-- so
as part of SAP, as I mentioned,
the core enabling
technology that we developed
called SAP HANA which provides
that in memory database
that powers our
solutions, provides
both analytical
and transactional
in the one instance.
So the traditional way of
doing business of an OLTP,
moving the data around,
and doing analysis
is really going away
from the SAP world
in the operational
world for our customers.
And that's where we're
talking about that.
The business-ready-- and
so, again, business-ready
from the point of view is,
is it really for consumption?
And can the business users have
that consumer-grade interface
again, rather than the green
screens that they were used to?
And on the top right,
the native cloud.
Of course, this is all
about the traditional stuff
that comes to mind when you're
talking about native cloud--
containerization, web scale,
and all the other things
along with it.
At that point, I'm
not really going
to get too much into it, because
the SAP aspects about cloud
native is related to the
SAP-centric development.
I'm not going to
say that you need
to go and build the next
greatest web app, consumer app,
on our platform versus
Google's platform,
because that's not
what it's designed for.
You can absolutely do it,
but the benefit really
comes when you're looking at
using the two in the enterprise
context.
So this is just another
kind of quick list
of the specific functions
and capabilities that
are behind these areas.
And what we're going to
be talking about today
is really along the
lines of the connection
aspects on the left-hand side.
As I mentioned, it's
the connected enterprise
at the end of the day.
Your apps, our
customers', partners' apps
are going to be
all about running
somewhat disconnected mode,
but fully integrated mode.
It's the fact that it's
got to be loosely coupled
is the way to go forward.
And one of the key things that
everybody has to make sure
is, when you're talking about
these intelligent enterprise
apps is, synchronization
and usage of the data.
So the master data governance
is absolutely important.
And secondly, the aspects about
the governance framework--
the one thing that
everybody seems to pass on
is that we have all these
beautiful, machine learning
algorithms making decisions.
And one thing that is required
in the enterprise world
is an audit trail.
Why was that action taken?
Now that's something that SAP
as an enterprise applications
vendor have at their heart
and soul, the fact that we
audit everything.
We can find out why did this
number become this number
and the reason behind it.
Now, think of this and
extrapolate this to,
you've got 500 algorithms
running and making
decisions and changes.
So now knowing what the decision
of this algorithm that was made
should be dependent upon
whatever constraints
it used at the time of
making that decision.
It is not like an end-user
clicking a button now.
We need to have the context.
So we will look at
enterprise applications
using artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
The governance framework
becomes very important as well.
These are, at the high
level, the capabilities built
inside the SAP Cloud Platform.
And when you're
looking at this, you're
thinking, well, yeah, OK.
I got all of these in my
native GCP components as well.
And some are absolutely
complementary
and have overlaps.
Some I would say
are even competitive
straight out of the box.
But it's the fact that
what we talk about as an
enabling technology to power
the business applications,
is how you leverage these
capabilities together
with the GCP services.
Because like I say, I'm going
to go into the use cases,
but this is an important aspect
of enabling the enterprise
apps into the new era.
Because, as I mentioned
before, it is very difficult
to turn every single enterprise
application into 10,000
micro services because of
the huge interdependencies
built into the process.
From a procure to
pay process, there
are thousands of dependencies
just inside it, let alone
outside it.
So can we now extend and
make use of the procure
to pay as a business
unit, as a function?
Yes.
It's called like
procurement in the cloud,
like we have with Ariba.
But when you start, if
you try to now decompose
each of those individually,
it becomes harder and harder
because of the interdependencies
that you have there.
But our goal here is really
to see how this platform can
broker that new innovation and
new technology at the lowest
level whilst maintaining
the business integrity
of the process itself.
And that's why we have created
a whole slew of use cases, what
we call the way
that we envision.
And I'm saying "we"
envision, because that's
the way that we designed.
It doesn't mean that our
customers and our partners
really end up making
use of it in that way.
Because once somebody's
given a particular tool,
they can make it do
anything they want.
One of the first
use cases is, as I
mentioned, experience and user
interface matters nowadays.
The green screen is
not the way to go.
So one of the key
things that we also did
is power as part of
our cloud platform
as this thing called
SAP Fiori Cloud, which
allows you to create,
basically an HTML5 based
GUI framework that front-ends
all the business transactions.
Now, I'm working with Google
as one of our customers.
And you can imagine,
Google, they
have some expectations on UI.
I believe they have some
experience in designing UI.
So they're like, this
is great, Damien.
But we use this
system as Angular.
And we're like, OK.
So you don't like our cool, new
front screens or UI screens?
You want to use your
own and develop yours?
Guess what, the way that we've
architected this and brokered
it, is allowing them to do that.
So they're actually
implementing things--
they were like, this
skin that you gave me,
forget that, here's my
JAVA, Angular-based skin.
I want to front-end it to
the business processes.
So all of these things that we
did to just enable and start
exposing things are being reused
by our partners and customers.
The other part of this framework
that's key is the extensions.
In the traditional ERP
world, not just SAP,
you had to basically
modify the core code.
And that got rolled out
with a version upgrade
as new capabilities came in.
That was the pain that
most CIOs, CTOs, as well as
business leaders lived through
as part of the upgrade process.
And what ended up happening
was, a lot of the time people
were just upgrading
the technical aspects
to stay current on support,
but I haven't really
updated any of my
business processes.
So even though I've
got a current system,
I'm still running it
as of 10 years ago.
So that's one of the
problems that was there.
And one of the
frameworks that we've
developed for cloud platform
is to get yourself out
of that framework.
I mentioned the
bimodal IT concept.
Back office functions,
those business services,
business objects, are
there to be served up.
But how you now
consume and extend
that is done
natively through what
we call the SAP Cloud Platform.
And that's one of the
use cases that it's
predominant used
by our customers
as well as our partners.
This other one here-- this
is an interesting one,
because I can actually say
we got there first to Google.
Because we actually
developed and realized
that API management
is key to our need
for consuming the
business applications
and developing what
we call the business
services at the end of the day.
We OEM'ed into our
platform Apigee.
So Apigee is our
API management tool,
which is obviously now the
Google-owned API management
tool.
And the reason for doing
that, as they realized also,
is the fact that we need to have
this governed, as I mentioned,
API structure into
our backend services.
And again, this because
one of the key reasons we
use this mechanism to power
the intelligent enterprises,
is because, as
developers and partners,
I don't expect you to know what
it takes to create a purchase
order and the gyrations that you
need to go through necessarily
in the purchase order
creation process,
or what the customer has
defined as mandatory fields,
mandatory process requirements,
or what workflows get
triggered on the back flow.
All of those things are
actually configured and managed
within SAP.
But as a front from the point of
view of developing or extending
those apps, just give
me a RESTful services
that says I can do an add
mode into a REST service,
and that's all you need to do.
And you can use the
JSON-based [INAUDIBLE]
or whether it's XML.
That's the beauty of
what we've done here,
is the fact that the
complexity of the back
is now really hidden.
or we provide a facade for you
to consume the backend business
functions.
The other part of this, it's
the IoT and the Extensions
Framework.
This, obviously, is built
natively into the SAP world,
because SAP, as I mentioned,
as a predominant business
applications provider,
hundreds of our customers--
probably thousands
of our customers--
have extensive IoT needs.
So we've develop
our own applications
suite capabilities built
into the SAP Cloud Platform.
Now, in the GPC world, I think--
I was just talking to a
developer across the road--
they were using
the GCP IoT core.
Now, the question
came to me, can you
integrate that with
our IoT capabilities?
Because they want to
now extend and make
use of our enterprise
asset management.
Because within the IoT framework
the simple part is not--
I shouldn't say simple, but the
capture of IoT events by itself
is half the story.
It's where did it
come from, what action
needs to be taken from it?
All of that information, guess
what, it's in our enterprise
asset management environment.
So the integration of GCP IoT
core into cloud platform IoT
is absolutely feasible, because
we've got a messaging bus,
we can integrate into Pub/Sub
as the messaging MQTT-based
message bus that
the IoT core uses.
The last one here,
as I said, this
is the one I'm kind of like, eh.
You have the options
of doing all of this.
This is just to show that
from the SAP point of view
we have the flexibility for
you to develop cloud native
applications in a
microservices-based
architecture which are using
the Cloud Foundry model.
So all of the
runtimes and languages
available from the
Cloud Foundry framework
is available natively.
The benefit for this,
again, as I mentioned,
is you have the
flexibility now to develop
brand new applications that
extend the CRM, that extend
the supply chain, using
the full-blown services
architecture that you're
familiar with as web native
or cloud native, but
still invoke and update
the backend processes.
Because at the end of the
day, I'm waiting for the day
that I can truly say that
every single S/4HANA ERP
service is a business
service and it's
delivered as a microservice.
That is going to be very
difficult I believe,
because there's a
lot of dependencies,
and it's more
efficient to run it
the way we're
doing it right now.
This one is just to give you an
idea of what I would consider
to be, I don't want to say
a reference architecture,
because I don't capture
every single scenario.
But what this does
show is something
that our customers
are already doing,
which is running S4 and
other business on-premise
applications, on HANA in GCP.
As you saw, a couple of
announcements that came out
this year, Google has caught
up with the competition
and already has 4-terabyte
virtual HANA systems available.
They are also now
leading the pack
in terms of providing
Optane chipsets supported
in S/4HANA as well.
The other part about this
also is the SAP Cloud Platform
that I mentioned is certified
to run on GCP as well.
So not only are the business
applications now running
on GCP, our platform
is running in GCP.
And over here, obviously, you
have the native GCP services
that everybody is making use
of as a developer out there.
And this is where the
interesting parts happen.
I think that is where all the
interests that you talked about
as this intelligent application
comes to the forefront.
I did that, and I
did this like this
to show you the interactions.
So at the end of the day,
a couple of developers
came up to me and said, well,
can I just write my service
straight into SAP?
And as you know, in any
world, given enough time
and resources, yes, you can.
But its a question of
why would you do that?
Because at the end of
the day, if the things
that we have going directly, as
you can see, into S4 and HANA
are things related
to the data aspects.
Because you want to be able
to pull into BigQuery data
directly from the SAP systems.
And that's what we've supported
as part of our capabilities
with our partnership.
But if you look
at the rest of it,
more of the interactions at the
business tier, the easiest way
to do it is to have it
brokered through the SAP--
what we call the Cloud
Platform services.
Why?
Because the SCP
services understands
everything SAP-centric.
And as much as we
like to say that, I've
got that simple
RESTful service, there
are implications on
still putting that PO in.
And then the fact
that, oh, you now
have to look at the
contract information
and things like that.
There are very
SAP-centric scenarios
hidden behind there in the
business services function.
So rather than doing an update
directly over on that side
and then worrying about
having to orchestrate
all those updates, we've
already done the orchestration
at this tier.
So from an external
consumption of services,
that's the path to go, because
that brokers out and allows
you to now make use of those
technologies and capabilities.
As a case in point--
I want to go into
details later on--
some of the AI
capabilities from here--
we actually had a
session yesterday,
talked about our
Deloitte partner
has created a
invoice entry screen
leveraging the AI capabilities
from the GCP stack.
It brokers in, calls in, the
necessary Fiori ODATA service
and consumes it and
puts the invoice in.
AUDIENCE: Is that
what it looks like?
DAMIEN JOHNSON: Oh, sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAMIEN JOHNSON: Sorry.
That's my IT, I'm afraid.
I can't change that
time-out session.
[LAUGHTER]
Security, security.
Sorry, what was the--
that was what you were
telling me, sorry.
Anyway.
So where was I?
So that's the reason why
we're looking at the brokering
aspects of our cloud platform.
And then if I get down into the
technical architecture, what
I did--
and I got a big caveat here.
This is conceptual design
scenarios only, right?
Because this has some
future scenarios.
But this is to give an overview
of how the actual brokering
consumption services
can really operate.
Because it's got things--
like I said, I didn't even
put it in the IoT core on GCP.
That's in there.
But things such as all the
machine learning, the Vision
API, and all those things--
I want to talk about
building a new app--
all of these capabilities that
come from the Google Cloud
Platform, all of the big
data stuff over there
on the left-hand side right.
And then, also, some of the
core infrastructure components,
such as the Kubernetes and
the containerization and what
is the compute engines.
If you look at this, the
way that it fits together
is to kind of identify the areas
where the connections occur.
So the big data
scenarios, guess what?
We have a component as
part of the Cloud platform.
It's called Data Hub.
It's been certified-- we're
going to get into the details
here--
that it works hand-in-hand
with BigQuery,
and Dataproc, and other
data platforms on GCP.
What does it do?
It brokers that service directly
into the business applications
on the integration side.
So Cloud Pub/Sub is the way
to go for most integration
scenarios in the GCP world.
We've got the ways of
integrating into that
at the messaging layer.
We have enterprise messaging
built into cloud platform.
We actually OEM Solus as our
Pub/Sub framework inside us.
But we also have native
integration services,
as I said.
So good, old-fashioned
RESTful services.
Oh, I shouldn't say--
Yeah, I guess, RESTfully
is old-fashioned now,
whenever the next wave comes in.
But [INAUDIBLE] web services,
et cetera, they're all provided.
And we have thousands
that you probably know.
We have these things
called inside SAP core--
did it get shorter--
from the point of view
of different services
invoking our business functions.
They can now be exposed,
consumed through this layer.
We have the aspects
of the CoPilot.
So one of the things
that I want to talk about
also is, I've shown it here
with the G Suite integrations,
we actually, for our
SAPPHIRE Session in May,
we announced and
showed how we've
integrated Sheets,
the first wave,
into the SAP applications,
Now, the reason
why I said this is
like we're trying to
have a single thread
through to the
integration scenarios.
So that's the way
we're looking at it.
And you can see over here
on the extends to the SA S/4
and their line of
business, i.e.,
if we're going to create
a conversational bot,
we don't want to create one
for this application, one
for that one, [INAUDIBLE]
that application.
More than development,
it's the fact
that when we are looking at
the conversational aspects,
it has to retain the
business context.
So as the conversation
flows through,
it can start off in our C/4HANA
hybrids or customer engagement
scenario, and
could theoretically
end up in a finance conversation
in our finance system related
to billing inquiries.
So because of that, we want
to maintain that context.
And that's why we have what
we call the SAP CoPilot, which
now makes use of those
machine learning capabilities
from our Leonardo functions.
And those same
Leonardo functions
is what can now
actually integrate
into all the Google Brain
and ML and CMLE functions,
and TensorFlow.
So that's to give
you a high level
view of the technical
scenarios that come together.
And so what I wanted to do
is to talk a little bit more
about what we've done
in concrete terms.
Everybody knows it's
all about the data,
the key areas of govern,
management and enrich,
and consume.
So at the end of the day,
I want to explain something
that I had in the
previous slide.
So when we look at the consumer
managed aspects, and enrich,
this is a scenario that's now
been released and it's working.
This is a way that SAP
S/4HANA can now basically
interconnect with Google
BigQuery, as well as a Pub/Sub
frameworks, as well as GCP
machine learning frameworks
via the cloud storage.
So in here is SAP
Data Hub, which
manages the flow of data
and orchestrates that.
That Data Hub also
now not only just
pushes data into and
reads from and manages
your overall orchestration,
but theoretically
if you are a GCP
user and have already
made use of extensive
data flows, guess what?
It's a question of
my previous diagram
I showed you-- it's about reuse.
So again, the core
principle here
is making sure that the
technologies available in GCP
are now fully integrated into
the business functions of SAP.
Because the one thing you don't
want to do in SAP, especially
in general in the RP enterprise
applications, is just
do database updates.
It's got to be the
application logic layer.
The other things that
of key importance
is experience and ease
of use, as I mentioned.
So from the SAP world,
we've basically released
and have available
key technologies that
allow you to do
all these things,
from the personas,
aspects for people,
and then the technology--
as I mentioned,
the machine learning libraries,
as well as REST-based API.
This is what the Google
team is re-skinning
via the REST-based APIs
into the business functions
that we've exposed.
As well as on the business side,
obviously, the integrations I
mentioned about, the
G Suite as well as
tighter integrations
with G Suite
through those CoPilot functions.
We have this.
This is probably not relevant
for GCPers in the crowd,
but this is part of the
whole suite of solutions
that comes along for the ride as
part of the SAP Cloud Platform
to allow you to do things.
This is where a
lot of the things
I mentioned before,
there might be
an overlap within the
specific functions
that you might be
using GCP to do.
But again, this is
the SAP-centric view,
but the point is that you
can now broker these services
into those external GCP
services without having
to learn the intricacies
of the SAP context.
The last one, and
obviously that's
relevant for most of the
people, these attendees here,
is looking at the way we
look at machine learning
and artificial intelligence.
The key difference
from SAP's world,
we are a world-leading
technology provider.
And this is what I started
off saying 20 years ago.
But it's a question
of, our technology was
developed to power our
business applications.
At the end of the
day, the technology
is about the business outcomes.
Technology is an enabler for us,
we are not a technology company
by itself.
It's all about developing the
right technologies to power
the business application
and the business process.
And that's why when we
look at this and say,
the way that SAP
approaches machine learning
and AI in general, and any
other innovation, new generation
of innovation technologies,
is with the business context
in mind, with the business
outcomes that our customers are
expecting.
So when I look at this, when
I talk about the machine
learning, the way that we
have attacked and started
to consume machine learning, is
to provide that core foundation
enablement.
We provide the
industry level context.
So we're looking at
blockchain, we're
looking at fraud detection in
the financial services world.
When we look at
consumer interaction
in our retail world,
we look at using
the relevant machine learning
algorithm technologies
that way.
Same goes for within the
procurement side, in sourcing.
So it's the industry context
that's applied by us.
It's not a generalized
algorithm out there
in terms of what we
want to look at it.
And the consuming apps--
again, our consuming apps are
our business applications.
So as I mentioned, things such
as in our financial world,
the way that we
apply cash is now
available via automated scenario
from a machine learning.
So the apps are our business
applications themselves.
That's really the
context from our point
of view, is the consuming apps
are our business applications.
And then the last one
there is bring your own.
So we have customers,
we have partners--
it's definitely got shorter--
from point of view
have developed
your own machine
learning algorithms
and perhaps have
your own models.
So the way that we've
architected our solution,
our technology
stack, is the fact
that you can bring your
own and make use of that.
So that's the same way that
we had, like I mentioned,
one of our partners, Deloitte,
bought their own machine
learning algorithm to model
to do the invoice creation
from a scanned OC image.
Looking a little bit at
the details behind this--
from the fact that we can
now also announce it's HANA 2
service pack 5, I believe.
We can do what's called
native TensorFlow serving.
So what this depicts is the fact
that within my SAP HANA world
I can make a call
out to TensorFlow,
pass it the relevant
information,
and have the inference
engine give me back results.
And then the other
side of this is
that we can now, using Data
Hub and all the data management
tools within SAP HANA,
move the relevant data
over to GCS, which is cloud
storage, which in turn is now
used by the CMLE engine
on the Tensor processing
units, retraining model using
the on-demand compute power
from the TPUs, and
updating that new model.
So you can have that nice little
continuous training function
applied.
And you can also, obviously,
with this, tune the model as
and when you need,
depending on that--
depending on the data
outcomes that you're having.
And since this is
a dev session, I
thought I better put a
bit of code in there.
So this actually
is the code to--
I don't know if you
can see this here--
call sys afl and
wrapper procedure.
The AFL is the application
function library inside HANA.
So to show you, it is real.
This is where it's making
that call out to the Tensor
serving engine.
And you getting back, as you can
see here, it's doing a predict.
And what it's doing,
is that this version
allows you to send in
multiple values or an array
for prediction.
Example use cases--
as I mentioned,
I think this is
going to be key here.
Sorry, I forgot to mention.
So before I get into
the example use cases,
as part of the
partnership, we've
actually developed brand
new solutions with Google.
The first of which is a solution
called SAP Data Custodian.
And as you probably can imagine,
this actually came out of--
I would say, Google
themselves made it relevant.
Because in the old
ways you used to deploy
SAP and other
enterprise applications,
you would have to deploy
multiple regional instances
because of the communications,
and the segregation duties,
and all of those things.
Now, with Google's high speed
interconnects across the globe,
you could theoretically have
a single instance scenario.
But the downside of the single
instance because of the GDPR
now, is all of who's
got access to what data,
and why are they
doing it that way?
So that's the solution that
we actually worked with Google
using their technology in
terms of access control
lists and security,
and seeing the logging
involved at the very lowest
level granular level.
And what we did is, obviously,
we provided, as I mentioned,
something that's key to SAP
is, process and governance.
So we provided the
governance framework
and the management of that
data flows and data controls.
It's not only about,
did you look at it?
I can now tell you, did you
have the right to look at
it, which is authorizations.
But did you have the right
usage base for that use?
Because just because you can
look at a social security
number because
you're in payroll,
why are you doing this from
within another function?
So all of those kind of
governance frameworks
is what SAP is good, and
that's what we've provided.
And that's, like I say, I think
you saw that on the keynote
today with [INAUDIBLE],, the
first iteration was released.
And we're working on it.
I'm not sure when the
next release level
is for the Data Custodian.
Another use case that I actually
worked with the Google team
for SAPPHIRE, was to take
a concept of an existing
SAP-based flow, which is all
about a fashion retail that
requires high touch
interaction with a customer,
and seeing if we can now
leverage the machine learning
algorithms inside the
cloud machine engine
in real-time to interact
with a store associate.
So the concept here was
that most marketing engines,
including SAP's, we can derive
a propensity to buy factor.
We identify, based
on your interactions
and your demographics, you
probably have a high propensity
to buy this particular product.
The next one we actually
worked with the customer
was, can I say,
well, which channel
should I offer this product
to the customer via?
Who should do it?
Should it be interactive?
Should it be via social
media, et cetera?
So that's where it
became a conversation.
And what we ended up doing, was
to say that, hey, wouldn't it
be great if we can
actually find a model that
allows us to do a prediction.
And that model that we
actually started with
is actually the YouTube
recommendation engine.
So we actually used
that, and we tweaked
it to create a scenario.
And this a very short
video that I've got.
It's to show what
we're going to have.
Basically, this is the
propensity to buy aspects.
So the CRM system has created a
list of products and customers,
and said, hey, this
is what we think.
Then the scenario
you can see here,
what we have on the right-hand
side, is say Assign All.
You'll see when I click
on that, it goes out.
Now, what it's
doing, is actually
that is a live call that
we did to the CMLE engine,
where we passed it
and we trained it
based on the historical
information of the sales
information.
And then, also, what we added to
that to make the model better,
is we actually
added in a function.
Because our assumption
going in was, generally
speaking, that an
associate would probably
have a higher success rate
selling or offering a product
that they personally think
is really good and they like.
So what we did is we
incorporated this scenario
of where the associates were
like, yeah, I like that,
or I don't like that.
So we were using that function
now into the training model
in addition to
just who sold what
in the past historical scenario,
to arrive at what we're calling
a seller affinity model.
And again, the last part of this
integration is, we did that,
we ran the model, and we're
actually trialing it through,
and the last part of this is to
leverage the SAP Cloud Leonardo
Analytics to put that
[INAUDIBLE] my HANA one--
there's a nice feedback loop.
We wanted to see if
what we're suggesting,
our hypothesis, is correct.
So as we actually
run the scenario,
we're going to run with
the analytics to say,
OK, here's all the ML
assigned assignments,
and here's the assignments
that were fed through as is.
So that's really
the way that we're
looking at extending our
capabilities in the workplace.
This is a conceptual
flow of what we did here,
just to give you a quick idea.
And this is where we
are really looking
at the ML functions being
used in the application tier.
The thing that we've got planned
for, is as part of those action
lists that came out from
that affinity model, the fact
that we have within the
machine learning foundation
from the Cloud Platform,
you have the ability
to now do resource leveling.
You can even factor in
not only sell this product
to that particular customer,
but you can actually now
factor in information regarding
profitability and pricing.
Because we've got access to
all of our retail information
and inventory information
inside Leonardo,
now I can provide the call
out to the Google engine with
the additional factors to
improve the model result set
coming back, i.e., you can
tweak the price of x,y,z,
because I've got a
lot of this in stock,
or keep it at full price,
because everybody in social
media is after the same product.
So all of those
aspects are built-in,
but we haven't exposed that yet,
because that's a business use
case.
That's really the power of what
our cloud platform is doing
versus just the native call
straight out to the Google ML
engine.
Because we can now provide that
business context right there
in Insight.
And again, since
I mentioned, this
is the actual
Python that's making
the call to that session.
Because I did say
it's a dev session.
The other one that I
wanted to highlight
was, we have a solution called
the S&P Product Information
Network.
And it's about having
all the material,
master data attributes about
consumer of consumer goods.
And we created this
scenario to say,
who's got the best, most
likely image library out there
right now?
And who actually exposes
that image library
through an open API
called Vision API--
it's Google.
So in this scenario we wanted
to say, oh, I like that chair,
take a picture of it.
And I know that people like
Amazon does it right now,
and it gives you, oh, it's a
chair, here all the chairs.
But what we did was
to find it now matched
that view, extracted
the attributes,
and then matched it on our
Productive Information Network
to find actual, real
life attributes,
like the fact that it's got the
color, the texture, the cloth
material, et cetera.
So it was matching at the
business attribute level
from our Product
Information Network.
And that's what this
area looks like.
So as you can see here, we're
using quite a few capabilities
from the backend
SAP GCP systems.
But again, from
our point of view,
it's not about just the
machine learning functions
that occur out in the
field, it is making sure
that we provide
the right business
context for the
consumption and then
the business processes
behind it as well.
So that was just to give
you a brief overview
of the key capabilities
and what we've done.
And I've got, in
the slides, ideas
about where to go and do this.
Downstairs, on level
one, SAP booth,
there are a couple
of hands-on tutorials
where you can
actually play around
with deploying HANA on GCP,
making use of the Android SDK
aspects as well.
So some of those are all there.
And I wanted to know, because
this is near drinking time,
I want to leave some
time for Q&A aspects.
So I'm free to take any
questions, because, like I
said, this was introductory.
People can find me on
LinkedIn, and if you've
got specific questions
about what the nuances are
about the enabling of
these technologies,
I'm absolutely free to help out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]